an idyllic sunrise over South Africa's
Impa malanga province this eastern part
of the country is home to thousands of
nature reserves and national parks that
draw in thousands of tourists from all
over the world every year but for the
local communities that live right on the
borders of these parts access is often
too expensive
two years ago Mike Kendricks founder of
local outreach program wild shots
started introducing children from local
government schools to the practical
skills of wildlife photography the aim
is to engage them in conservation game
drives and show them the value and
beauty of these wild places through
photography really the photography is
just a vehicle for getting the kids
interested in animals getting them
interested in wildlife in war places and
giving them an experience of what a
tourist sees or maybe in some cases what
their father or what their mum sees when
they're working in a lodge mike has been
running the program by himself since it
started most of the funding in cameras
come from donations the NGO says it's
crucial to expose local communities and
young people to conservation activities
to encourage them to actively
participate this could help spread
awareness about living in harmony with
nature about sharing the land and even
help create community initiatives so if
you're a young person growing up in
these communities you've got a couple of
choices here you could look at the
poaching route and that brings
short-term high high monetary gain or if
you've been on my program you might be
able to see a longer-term solution in
that if the animals are there for a
sustainable number of years into the
future then we've got tourism we've got
jobs we've got employment going on for
our children and for the grandchildren
going forward down the road in a small
village of Bismarck nan de ferran dabeli
leads a typical teenage girl's life she
helps out with chores around the house
in-between her schoolwork
but this morning is a little different
for her as a graduate of the program she
is joining her classmates on her first
game drive where they'll be putting
their new skills to the test so now I
know everything I ever come here
even a the parts of chimera I didn't
know that looking after in menses
entertained England and now I know that
looking after in versus school because
of it
we've benefited from that the lessons
she's land may have shipped her future
when she leaves school and then
defending Billy wants to become a
zoologist and teach people about animals
and how important they are for the
country more than a thousand rhinos have
been poached in the kruger national park
every single year for the past five
years
don't be shy a local game Ranger
attended the same second school as this
children today he supports the wild
shots project together with other
colleagues I think when you sent the
photography some of the people they
don't have their advantage to come in
their bush when able to show them the
pictures our body for the animals they
will learn more about the nature gonna
have been a very very big huge impact
for the communities to against more
knowledge about the bush the people they
were used to come here and put in the
impalas using this nice so that they can
have a meal but now as the Challenger
knows we mustn't do hunting they will
well explain to other people even their
parents you mustn't or and kill the
animals because it's our nature wild
shots has trained nearly 300
schoolchildren so far
the NGO also organized an exhibition
last year to showcase some of the
students work and now while Schatz has
been asked to take the initiative to
Kenya and other countries across the
continent